People turn to possession by very,
very strict ideological ideas.
And you know,
they were willing to be possessed by
those ideas to the point where they would
undertake actions that you'd think
would be completely impossible for
theoretically civilized people.
You know,
it turned out that those actions,
not only,
we're not impossible for civilized people,
but that the people themselves,
you know,
especially in Nazi Germany,
they pretty much knew what
the hell was going on.
You know,
you don't take several million people
out of your population without rumors
spreading,
let's say.
And so,
you know,
we should never forget
that Hitler was elected,
you know,
and he was elected by a
large margin majority too.
It was a landslide vote.
The kind of vote that no modern
democratic leader ever gets.
So,
you know,
although it's difficult to,
it's difficult for people to swallow.
Um,
it's hard not to assign culpability for
what happened in Germany to the society
at every strata.
You can't just dump it on the leaders.
And in fact,
one of the things that,
here's,
here's something to think
about with regards to Hitler.
So,
because one of the
things you might ask is,
how the hell could he be so,
so absolutely compelling to his audiences.
But here,
here,
I'll give you an explanation.
So let's,
let's make the,
let's make a few assumptions.
The first assumption is there are a lot
of resentful Germans kicking around.
Why?
Well,
they lost the first world war.
That wasn't so good.
And then there were a lot of brutal man
left because they'd been in the trenches
and they'd been shooting,
fighting and shooting at each other under
absolutely a Borat conditions for like
years and years.
And so there were plenty
of brutalized men around.
Um,
and then their whole damned economy
collapsed because they were forced into
signing what historians regard
is a very punitive peace treaty.
And so,
like,
everything had fallen apart to a degree
that we can't even begin to imagine.
And so,
you know,
in the 1930s,
the Germans were starting to
get back on their feet and,
and,
um,
when Hitler came to power,
he started not only to rearm but
to reindustrialization the economy.
And he was actually
pretty damn good at that.
So now Hitler was a good orator,
but he,
it isn't exactly clear that he was a,
a coherent philosophical fear riser.
Although to think of him as stupid as
it is completely missing the point,
he was by no means stupid.
Um,
I wouldn't say that he
was particularly educated,
but he had a very powerfully developed
aesthetic sense and he spent a lot of his
time designing the cities that would
be built after World War II was over in
those cities were generally
conceptualized by him,
has places where the arts,
or at least the Nazi version
of the arts could flourish.
You know,
so there's no real evidence that what
was wrong with the Nazis was that they
were civilized.
There's more evidence,
actually,
I think that they were
two civil civilized.